e
à la rouelle lettres russes? Le
temps nous le dira.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans la légendaire Graceland
Wedding Chapel, pas de
traditionnelle marche nuptiale.
C'est au son d'Elvis que Katy
et Joe ont choisi d'unir
leur destinée, un couple formé
durant la pandémie.
(applaudissements)
- Nous avons décidé de nous
marier à Vegas car tout était
fermé à cause de la COVID.
Nous ne voulons pas attendre
deux ans, alors nous sommes
venus à Vegas.
- Et pourquoi pas être marié par
Elvis? Que demander de mieux?
- Par les temps qui courent,
des mariages comme celui-ci,
Brendan Paul en célèbre
jusqu'à 45 par jour.
La ville a traversé des crises,
mais d'une telle magnitude,
Brendan Paul n'en avait jamais
connue.
BRANDON PAUL, proprio célébrant,
Graceland Wedding Chapel
- Quelle année éprouvante pour
une ville basée sur le tourisme!
Voir Vegas dans cet état,
c'était crève-coeur et terrible
économiquement.
- Las Vegas, ce paradis
artificiel, au milieu
du désert a connu la pire crise
économique de son histoire.
Pour se réinventer après
les attentats du 11 septembre
et la récession de 2008,
Vegas avait accéléré
son virage familial et misé sur
Céline Dion. Cette fois encore,
la diva de Charlemagne vient
à la rescousse.
MARY BETH SEWALD, pdg,
Chambre de commerce de Las Vegas
- Las Vegas l'a accueillie
à bras ouverts. Elle a redéfini
le monde du divertissement
à Las Vegas, elle a lancé
une mode et réellement changé
les choses.
- La majorité des touristes
internationaux ne sont pas
encore de retour, mais dans
les rues, les bars, les hôtels
ou les casinos, à l'exception
des employés, presque plus
personne ne porte le masque,
ni ne craint la promiscuité.
- Nous voyons enfin la lumière
au bout du tunnel et ce n'est
pas un train. Le Resort World
vient tout juste d'ouvrir.
- Resort World est projet
titanesque de 4,3 milliards
de dollars. Il vient tout juste
d'être inauguré. Et à compter
de novembre, il accueillera
en résidence Céline Dion.
JOHN NELSON, premier
vice-président, AEG Live
- L'industrie du divertissement
a dépassé celle des jeux
de hasard. C'est pourquoi
il était crucial pour un nouveau
venu, comme le Resort World,
de s'imposer en présentant
des concerts de superstars.
- La fête a repris et Vegas a
hâte de se remettre de sa gueule
de bois, mais le pari est
risqué. Ici, 40 % de
la population est vaccinée
et le déconfinement
est extrêmement rapide.
Toutefois, le poumon économique
artificiel du Nevada peut
compter sur une autre carte
cachée dans sa manche :
le Cirque du Soleil qui,
à travers les néons,
s'apprête à briller à nouveau.
Parce qu'à Vegas,
il faut croire en sa chance.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, L